harnessing the power of gods and
fighting epic battles in lava sounds
like a typical Dragon Ball super
experience this is what you may not know
about Dragon Ball super Broly
like the two preceding Dragon Ball Z
films 2013's Battle of Gods and 2015's
Resurrection F Broly is written by
Dragon Ball Creator Akira Toriyama the
legendary Creator had Grand plans for
the 2018 film in an interview with the
official Dragon Ball site director
tatsuya nagamine revealed that after
storyboarding toriyama's original script
the movie was projected to run for twice
the intended length Broly was planned to
run for approximately 90 minutes with
nagamine feeling that the script
Toriyama had written was enough to cover
two feature films nagamine worked
closely with the producer and the rest
of the production crew to trim down
toriyama's script to a more manageable
100 minute run time while retaining the
Dragon Ball Creator's vision
nagamine has been a prominent animator
and filmmaker with toy animation for
years working not only on Dragon Ball
super but also on the long-running
one-piece anime series and several of
its films with Broly possessing its own
animation style nagamine recruited two
of his prior collaborators from the 2012
anime film one Piece Film Z to work with
him on the Dragon Ball super project in
the Dragon Ball official site interview
nagamine cites both background animator
nobihiro Sue and animation director now
hiroshitani has prominent past one piece
colleagues he brought on to work with
him for Broly while the animation team
brought their own visual Flair to the
production they were keenly aware that
iconic imagery such as Super Saiyan
Transformations and the Kamehameha waves
were firmly established in fan
expectation nagamine instructed the
animators to feel free to use modern
technology rather than rely entirely on
traditional methods to bring the movie
to life nagamine reasoned that just as
Goku has evolved and grown over the
course of Dragon Ball so too should the
visuals behind the franchise
though toriyamo wrote the screenplay for
Broly and provided character designs for
the film his contact with the production
crew was limited according to the
theatrical program for Broly distributed
with the Japanese release of the film
nagamine spoke with Toriyama only once
during a private advanced screening for
the film's staff nagamine admitted he
did not consult with Toriyama before
starting production on Broly feeling he
had toriyama's tacit blessing to do the
provided script Justice Prior to Broly
nagamine adapted toriyama's work with
the Dragon Ball super anime series and
the 2007 short film Dr slump nakamine
felt that these experiences helped him
understand toriyama's storytelling
nuances and Stylistics sensibilities and
kept them in mind during production
though burley's past appearances in the
franchise had been considered
non-canonical to the overarching
continuity the Legendary Super Saiyan
had become a significant fan favorite
character in an interview with the
official Dragon Ball website nagamine
revealed he felt a special
responsibility as his mentor shigayasi
yamaluchi directed Broly's debut in the
non-canonical 1993 film Dragon Ball Z
Broly the Legendary Super Saiyan this
led to the production crew taking a
careful and methodical approach in
animating Broly's action for his
canonical introduction to the franchise
nakamine sought to evoke the feeling of
raw power and strength that Broly exuded
in his prior appearances nagamire worked
on many of the action sequences
storyboards himself and estimated that
300 to 400 storyboards were created for
Broly's actions and movements alone this
thorough attention to detail made for a
carefully designed Legendary Super
Saiyan with every action meticulously
plotted out as he battled the heroes in
the film
while Toriyama provided character
designs for a long line of non-canonical
Dragon Ball Z anime films his input on
their Productions was limited at best
while he helped design Broly for
Legendary Super Saiyan he admitted in a
tweet years later that he wasn't really
involved in the production when an
editor suggested incorporating Broly
into the Dragon Ball super era as the
centerpiece of the 2018 movie Toriyama
had to re-watch the character's prior
appearances as he had forgotten
important details about the stories he
was involved in in revisiting Broly's
past appearances Toriyama saw an
opportunity to reintroduce a different
version of the character that was more
closely linked to the Saiyan's tragic
history with Frieza Toriyama kept the
classic image of Broly in mind from
these non-canonical films while setting
out to create a more fascinating version
of the character
Broly has historically towered over his
opponents overpowering them with the
sheer might of his brute strength and
that remains true for his redesign in
the movie in the promotional program for
the film's Japanese theatrical release
shintani recalls receiving the designs
for the new Broly feeling they were
noticeably different from his previous
appearances with all of the character
designs that he received depicting Broly
and armor shintani added his own touch
to the redesign and wanted to get him
out of his armor shintani revealed that
the only design directive he received
from Toriyama was not to depict Broly as
quote overly Macho in the final film
taking that note in mind shintani strobe
to depict Broly as physically imposing
as possible without going overboard and
demonstrating the Saiyan's overwhelming
power thank you very much I am grateful
in the finished film in contrast to his
bare-chested prior appearances Broly
maintains his armor through his fights
against Vegeta and Goku before losing it
in a fit of rage at the end of the movie
with the battle against Broly lasting
for most of the film The Clash begins in
an Arctic location on Earth before the
snowy environment is completely
destroyed the fighting only intensifies
however with exposed magma burning below
the combatants before the Skirmish
begins to shatter the walls to reality
though this changes up the visual
Aesthetics of the movie's environments
and the fight itself nagamine had even
more ambitious plans for the film's
climactic boat in the theatrical program
for Broly's wide release in Japan
nagamine revealed that he had considered
having the fight progress into outer
space near the Earth's sun or deeper
within the planet's core in addition to
changing up the scale of the battle the
settings would be a clear homage to
similar sequences in the non-canonical
anime film Dragon Ball Z Broly Second
Coming however these plans were dropped
to accommodate the final film's 100
minute run time
Frieza plays a prominent role in Broly
after being resurrected at the end of
the Dragon Ball super anime series in
exchange for his assistance during the
tournament of power the late voice actor
Christopher Ayers provided the English
dub performance for Frieza in the film
reprising the role he had held since the
2010 anime series Dragon Ball Z Kai
tragically airs performance in Broly
would be the last time he portrayed the
character before passing away in October
2021. Ayers endured end-stage chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease and
underwent a double lung transplant to
treat the serious condition prior to
playing Frieza in Broly the procedure
and disease left Ayers with 11 lung
capacity meaning the actor had to bring
two to three oxygen tanks with him to
recording sessions Ayers would take
himself off of his oxygen supply long
enough to record a handful of lines as
Frieza before taking a break to resume
his oxygen intake however this is
proving to be far too interesting to
pass up this arduous process would
similarly be used by heirs to record the
final episodes of Dragon Ball super
underscoring his dedication to the role
nakamine is a credited co-director on
the anime series Dragon Ball super for
the latter half of its run working with
fellow co-director ryota Nakamura while
the last stretch of episodes was
produced concurrently with Broly
nagamine intended to maintain his full
directorial responsibilities helming
both projects simultaneously to see
Dragon Ball super through to the end
nakamine's intentions were overruled by
toy animation however who had him
instead Focus his primary efforts on
directing Broly rather than the
television series in an interview with
the official Dragon Ball website
malcolmine admitted he wanted to finish
what he had started with Dragon Ball
super but felt Nakamura did a good job
closing up the series with the show also
ending in 2018 several months before
Broly's release nagamina was able to
give the future film Project his full
attention while Nakamura worked
diligently on the series
in the Dragon Ball Manga and Anime
bulma's home and the headquarters of her
family's company capsule Corporation are
based out of West City Broly features an
early scene set at bulma's Seaside home
as she entertains beerus and whis while
Goku and Vegeta Spar nearby over the
ocean in designing the second home for
Bulma malcolmedia was personally
inspired by a recent family vacation he
had taken on the coast of Italy to add
to the film's varied environments an
early design for bulma's Coastal Home
noticeably resembled the Amalfi Coast in
Italy where nakamine and his family had
visited eagle-eyed Dragon Ball fans
noticed the scenic inspiration from the
film when the background artists shared
an early look at several environments
for Burley months ahead of its premiere
as Vegeta's duel against Broly escalates
the Saiyan Prince transforms into a
red-haired Super Saiyan God to even the
odds against the Legendary Super Saiyan
the movie marks the on-screen debut of
Vegeta making the transformation despite
him using these significantly more
powerful super saiyan blue form
throughout the anime series Dragon Ball
super in episode 27 of Dragon Ball Super
Vegeta shows off his ability to reach
the Super Saiyan blue transformation
surprising everyone but a proud Goku
yeah and unlike me Vegeta didn't have
the benefit of absorbing the energy from
the Saiyan ritual he had to figure it
out all from scratch Vegeta's use of the
Super Saiyan God transformation in Broly
finally shows him unveiling the form in
action before Goku steps in to continue
the fight
before Goku and Piccolo teach Vegeta how
to perform the Fusion dance so he and
Goku can join together to form Gogeta
they maneuver Broly into attacking
Frieza to buy themselves time though no
specific time frame is given for the
Skirmish in the film Piccolo reminds the
two Saiyans that each Fusion lasts for
30 minutes before they separate and can
perform the dance again with Goku and
Vegeta botching the Fusion Dance twice
before finally mastering it this means
Frieza battles Broly alone for over an
hour before Gogeta arrives on the
battlefield whereas the film only
provides glimpses of the fight between
Frieza and Broly the battle is expanded
upon in the manga adaptation in his
golden form Frieza is able to actually
deliver some palpable hits on Broly that
are enough to briefly stagger his
opponent though he still finds himself
outmatched by the Saiyan's raw Fury in
contrast Frieza endures the beating of
his life before Gogeta steps in to
finish the fight for good
Broly saw the feature film debut of
voice actor Ayah hisakawa in the iconic
role of Bulma for its Japanese language
track hiromitsuru who had been voicing
Bulma since the original Dragon Ball
series in 1986 passed away in November
2017 from an aortic dissection Broly
marked hisakawa's full debut in the role
as the character only silently appeared
in the Dragon Ball super series finale
over the end credits sequence following
Broly hiskawa has continued to play
Bulma in the franchise including the
film's 2022 sequel Dragon Ball super
superhero
as Goku and later Gogeta fight against
Broly the announcer is heard eagerly
hyping up the proceedings over the
film's soundtrack
the decision to include this auditory
flare was inspired by nagamine observing
the lengths Mexican fans went in their
unauthorized promotion of the Dragon
Ball super series finale Goku's
climactic boat against jiren in the
anime series was publicly broadcast
while Maca posters hyping up the fight
were produced in an interview with my
Navi nagamine revealed that these
unsanctioned fan promotions inspired him
to add a fight announcer to Broly to
evoke a similar sense of energy nakamine
felt that the addition enhanced the
enjoyment of the fights and encouraged
audiences to revisit them to reignite
that thrill in repeat viewings
foreign